on va revenir sur tout ce qui s'est
passé en télé et partout sur tout ce qui
s'est passé encore parce que on veut
vous divertir et aussi qu'on apprenne
des choses et j'ai une première question
à poser la question je la pose et à
sophie cause puisque sophie cost nous
avait avoué qu'elle avait une petite
aventure avec lui avant bien sûr quand
il était célibataire et que oui c'est
denis brogniart la question contre qui
denis brogniart at il poussé un coup de
gueule sur instagram contre les gens qui
sortent dans la rue contre le totem de
koh lanta qui ne répond pas à ses appels
contre ceux qui se font passer pour des
candidats de koh lanta sur les réseaux
ou contre les patrons d'edf
sophie koch centre les gens qui des gens
qui sortent dans la rue entre les gens
qui sortent de la rue et sophie koch le
connais bien puisque je rappelle qu'elle
a embrassé denis brogniart même je crois
qu'elle a vu son totem regarde la
réponse alors je voudrais une nouvelle
peau pousse un coup de gueule pas contre
toi moussa mais j'en ai ras-le-bol de
voir tous cuse et moi c'est imbécile qui
prennent des pseudo constat identique
aux comptes des candidats de koh lanta
je passe mon temps à dire à l'homme dit
ah bah ouais non mais tu as dit que
j'avais dit ça mais c'est pas moi parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui a le même compte
toi tu as eu ce problème là moussa si
vous pouviez s'il vous plaît
mais prenez un compte avec votre nom
n'importe quel pseudo mais je trouve
qu'il n'ya rien de pire que ce
s'identifier à quelqu'un d'autre et à
prendre la place de quelqu'un d'autre
c'est quand même hyper voyez je connais
vraiment bien mais c'est vrai gilles
gernez profit tout ce qui s'est passé
pour le téléspectateur
ça en fait donc denis brogniart il fait
d'aider des live avec des candidats et
c'est très à la mode
2 comme ils sont pas tous certifiés ya
plein de gens comme koh lanta est très
populaire et à garder qui prennent des
pseudos qui créent des fausses
polémiques qui taillent d'autres
candidats qui critiquent des
téléspectateurs et brogniart est un peu
le
le gardien du temple et c'est tout à
fait normal finalement avec lui il dit
on arrête alors là c'est du jeu mais
parfois il ya des gens qui des tons des
pseudos et ses plus bas donc à ces
débordements
il faut que chacun soit chacun je suis
d'accord tu d'accord avec toi et avec
denis brogniart oui jean michel j'aime
beaucoup ce film et je trouve ça un peu
irrespectueux vis-à-vis du public de
travailler aussi que les émissions et
les médias
soit les gens me l a du charme j'ai
beaucoup travaillé quand même sur le
sujet denis brogniart on a bien sûr
aussi c'est vrai à tous et vous savez
tout connaître de nuit a pas des charges
à la décharge de denis également des
surette 4 mariages pour une lune de miel
qu'est ce qu'une candidate aurait voulu
à la place des chants religieux à
l'église du jean jacques goldman du
gospel festif duos l'enfoiré ou du bob
sinclar on va demander à beinheim je
veux dire une légende à deux mains et
l'ong human valérie bénaïm bien sûr
sofico spécialiste média de 0,4 à 2 nuls
et 1 0 aux siens
c'est votre travail à valérie bénaïm il
faut désormais aller regarder
regardez
[Musique]
il
trouver un nom de ces mots c'est tout
c2box et voilà valérie benaïm encore ils
voulaient du bob sinclar voilà valérie
vous allez bosser un petit peu les
émissions bah oui je sais j'ai géré tout
mon soutien d'autres choses
ouais c'est ça jean michel et là encore
j'imagine aucune sanction
il en aura jean michel vous inquiétez
pas le droit d on va parler à 2,90
minuit en quelque 90 banques dont 90
minutes enquête et un vacancier au
camping qui se plaint de ne pas pouvoir
faire une chose mais quoi
gilles verdez faire un barbecue péter
sans réveiller les voisins avoir des
bières fraîches à disposition ou
regarder la série le renard
tranquillement sur france 3 était
semblait sans déranger les voisins n'ont
henin voilà quelqu'un qui fait qu'ils
travaillent voilà quelqu'un qui a du
hockey parfait
un camping familial ici pas question de
réveiller les enfants
pas de musique à fond jusqu'à l'aube ces
spécialistes de la fête
kevin en tête accusent le coup grosse
erreur de camping enfin disons que tu
pètes tueur et les voisins d'autant
c'est bob iger nord si tu perds tu
réveilles les voisins c'est vrai que
l'afp s'était sont vos problèmes le mec
il va au camping que pour péter un an
moi mon truc au camping csb qui fait b
que pour péter bale heureusement on a
pas mal jacques attali qui aurait pu
s'entendre reprocher son interprète
selon quelle est la particularité de la
première fois d'un couple qu'on a vu
dans les amours alors la première fois
d'un couple qu'on a vu dans les âmes
je vais demander alors 11,5 et laurence
j'ai posé la question qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ça a duré trois secondes 12
le mec a vomi juste après la fusion b
dans les pommes où ils se sont engueulés
pendant l'acte ça a duré trois secondes
laurence les mécanos tgl voit pas que je
souhaitais mais non ça dure et que
beaucoup de regards et alors avec kevin
lénine entre bouaflé bref c'est pas
différence pour moi c'est le même moule
bâbord ce n'était pas génial mais ça
peut être pas génial pendant une plombe
bref c'est que ça peut être très bien
mais ça a duré sept secondes 12 mois 312
les conditions faisait que lettre à la
poste
comme on dit c'était pas des conditions
on était chez un ami à lui
c'est après faut qu'on dormait à deux
ils amis étaient là on est éloquente le
stress et 3 secondes
ouais kevin au pica et il est franc le
bec a alors genre se poser la question
c'était quand votre première position
comment votre première fois tiens je
vais demander à gilbert dez s'était
alors moi c'était un très mauvais
souvenir pour la jeune femme est pour
moi un champ au doigt et toute en fleurs
c'était une super bonne santé nommé
laurence comme je suis allergique et
tous vidés sur elle ça a été une
tragédie je vais il admirait pour être
très parce que les familles ne regarde
que tout est sorti en même temps l'âge
et zermatt
malgré ses membres va merci sophy cost
vous tout en restant bien sûr correct
sophie cost alors la première fois
c'était avec un garçon qui était
beaucoup plus âgée que moi et je me suis
senti un petit peu je dois dire démunis
et je pense que comme la plupart des
jeunes filles que j'avais 17 ans à
l'époque
franchement c'était pas une super
expérience c'est à dire que j'étais
plutôt en train d'attendre que ça se
passe c'est que ça se termine et sophie
copains ici c'est parce que faustine
bollaert 1 c'est pas ça quand je vous
disais c'est tout donc l'on pouvait
raconter des trucs un peu voilà
sympathiquement
ah c'est le thème du truc laurent
souvenir oui laurence faille et moi
j'étais maire mieux parce que c'est un
italien extraordinaire et en plus j'en
étais très amoureuse est lui aussi en
plus c'était un homme très doué en la
matière a dit que j'étais nul tout à
l'heure mais trois secondes ou c'est pas
possible il a menti à la monte de 3,12
merci on à madame premier degré un
exportateur et moi non en version n'a
pas envie de savoir vous êtes salle
pourquoi philippe etchebest vous c'est
sale et beinheim c'est comme ma soeur
j'ai paris savoir pourquoi monsieur best
at il fait une telle reese arrière dans
top chef
parce qu'il a dû aussi découvert à quoi
ressemblait une palourde royale parce
qu'un candidat la plaie cyril lignac
part qu'un candidat oublié de mettre de
l'eau pour faire cuire son bris ou parce
qu'elle a eues il a eu la bouche en feu
jean michel maire sans vouloir vous
déranger banon me dérangeait pas
j'essaie de voir les à la télévision les
gars il est alors alors entendu bon bah
rien parce qu'il regarde tu avais marre
d'être au mollet ol mollet il est la
recherche assez ça ok ça c'est peut-être
là c'est sa seconde là d'accord j'en
connais ses choix
il vient épicer bien pimentée on a le
cacao on à l'arachide
[ __ ] oui par bam bam bam bam à ses
oies ou taxer ces condiments
ça envoie
ok clip on y verse une larme avait agité
de spasmes
j'ai presque envie de l'aider ah oui
d'annoncer en syrie la syrie je dirais
la réponse des passes qui la bouche on
se bat dit gilbert les chili question il
jour sophie koch à il ya une vidéo super
mignonne qui tourne actuellement d'un
papillon anglais dans une maison de
repos
il se met à pleurer après avoir reçu un
cadeau c'est une vidéo qui a fait
chavirer le monde antique
pourquoi moi j'aime à moi je serai un
coussin avec la photo de sa femme
décédée un message vidéo de ses petits
enfants qui chantent pour lui un cd
dédicacé de son chanteur préféré gras
dur ou un livre sur les aspirines
préfacé par benjamin castaldi et sedo
libre je vous met en scène une vidéo
minutes j'ai enlevé ses deux minutes
pour réfléchir à votre garde et on se
retrouve dans deux minutes si vous êtes
en famille alors là vous avez dû être
ému par cette vidéo c'est cette vidéo
qui tourne d'un papy anglais dans une
maison de repos et il se met à pleurer
après avoir reçu un cadeau et ce cadeau
c'est un coussin avec la photo de sa
femme décédée
regardez ça fait pleurer tout le monde
c'est vraiment la vidéo qui a le plus
tourné aujourd'hui regarde un adieu
presents entamé à aa
oh et il s'appelle ken bengo il à 94 ans
est vu comme ils effraient 95 ans c'est
un vétéran de l'armée britannique et le
choc de perdre son épouse aïda il y a
neuf mois et en trois jours la vidéo a
été vue près de 15 millions de fois sur
twitter ça c'est vraiment un
magnifiquement oui jean michel way avec
astana aurait été moins émouvant
s'ordonne coussin péteur à laquelle
lourdeur valérie rattraper moi ça vous
plaît il faut savoir c'est que depuis sa
femme est décédée et qu'il dormait tout
le temps et les jeunes femmes qui
s'occupent de lui se sont rendu compte
avec la photo de sa femme pourtant
contre son coeur dans la main et elles
sont rendu compte de ça et à sidi bouzid
auto et l on fait le fameux coussins km
en cycle mixte
c'est génial c'est aller dans incroyable
transformation sur m6 est ce qu'une
femme préfère à sa famille préfère fois
sa voiture
frédéric françois sa collection de
brosse de toilette ou ces animaux
beinheim
c'est d'animaux mais naim regarder et si
vous avez une bonne réponse j'ai
naïvement vous reconnais la place et le
cachet de jean michel merle haggard
c'est toi tes titres il faudra un petit
peu soin de toi qu'est ce qui se passe
là oh bah tout lâcher ben j'ai tout
lâché je suis je suis à la retraite je
croyais plus c'est pas une hérésie
j'habite à la campagne alors 1er mai
chien avec des talons aiguilles
rien de mieux pour plein mais moi
maintenant je fus personnes qui me
regarde si on est là aujourd'hui c'est
juste orient sarah ba ba oui mais je
pensais pas qu'ils me regardent d'euros
tant que ça en fait non mais j'ai envie
de la secouer la moi je suis d'accord
avec toi mais qu à moi aussi j'ai envie
de la ccoo et non mais mais sarah
comment ça se fait que tu préfères tu es
animaux à ta famille mais ben au moins
quand je leur parle de me répondre
je peux crier une disent rien
on sent toujours avec moi qu'on
m'entende c'est pas une vie sans comme
amant mais c'est pas gênant de faire ça
devant les animaux quand ils sont pas là
ils sont pas toujours avec nous et 24
heures sur 24
sa coupe apple l'élan après nous n'avons
plus de
de relation comme avant quand même à ma
peut-être parce que j'ai vieilli voilà
n'importe quoi voilà bomba est à vos
débuts cette émission dirait vraiment
une parodie sans régler ses tableaux
alors on fait des gros jeux et cirés
qu'elle préfère c'est anigo à sa famille
voilà il ya ces gars y'a plein de gens
comme ça à l'air de rien voilà jean
michel je sais que vous avez un chien et
qu'il n'avait pas de famille donc
forcément votre chien c'est votre
famille collection question 9 pour
question mise d'ailleurs pour jean
michel maire une question sur le prénom
gilles dans les 12 coups de midi at on
appris à les achever la poser à gildas
york at-on appris sur les hommes se
prénommant gilles dans les douches rugby
ils ont un très beau jeu ce sont les
cocus ce sont des caves à l'heure où ils
ont un sex-appeal de ouf
pour ce que j'en sais là des ses lattes
et forcément ils ont un fils fouet
attendu et oui ma ville et je vous
confirme que gilles verdez un sex-appeal
mais bon les piles maillon question
étymologiquement parlant pour quelles
raisons devrait-on se méfier d homme
prénommé guillaume gille
étymologiquement seulement je tiens à le
préciser
soit il serais menteur soit l'autre à ce
tir et menteur derrière l'autre
peut-être que étymologiquement il serait
cavaleur il serait qu'à valeur oui en
fait les prénoms guillaume et gilles
sont issus du verbe dizier qui signifie
tromper dans une idée de séduction comme
d'encourir le guillou d'où le gueut noah
laguiller guilidoux oui et d'ailleurs
elle n'est pas qu'on affublait de ces
prénoms les faiseurs de cocu marche et
oui j louer ou pas et c'est logiquement
voilà par exemple
il paraît que benjamin ont été mauvais
jugement ça veut dire gros petter mais
c'est vrai voilà allez on va à terme à
quatre années de retour on va lui poser
une question qu'elle puisse colonnes et
est ce que ça marche ça ne marche pas
oui mais on est on est pas là pour ça
question quelle personne at on vu donc
quelle personne a tout vu dans un dîner
presque parfait le rôle là relou à qui
on peut rien dire là relou qui n'aime
rien là relou qui fait tout mieux que
tout le monde
oula relou qui ne dit pas free mes
pommes frites
khatali laroque la relooker dit pommes
frites et bien castaldi ce qu'arrive une
réponse une connerie
regardez on sait qu'elle va grignoter
mais bon je picore et ses dauphines
alsacienne un jour antennes gsm lui j'en
comprends que je vaux dans la vie et
essayer des choses qu'on laissait de
côté ont laissé de s'intéresser à les
choses même parfois qui peuvent être
surprenante pour avoir bossé c'est est
ce qu'on me donne des ordres ne comptera
donc nous sommes pas non je demandais si
tu me demandes messieurs par une ferme
ne s'est pas battu fumeurs si criant n'a
rien à faire en fait de tes conseils je
fais ce que je veux j'ai envie de goûter
de ma manière le goût de ma manière
voilà il n'est pas là pour donner des
ordres ni des conseils étaient pas mon
père autres pas ma mère voilà quoi et ça
je crois dans ta vie tu en sais j'aime
pas laissé une seule dans sa vie mais
juste que je le gère ma vie comme les
envies de la vérité j'aime bien quand tu
parles comme ça c'est bon quoi ces
radicaux jean-louis l'algérie quoi c'est
bon quoi
mais c'est pas le vieux sage de la mer
la grimace quoi tu es mon poids et à la
limite tu te moques de moi est lié le
roquefort qui dit au camembert tu pues
quoi ça va mon parcours je soulage
maintenant tiens on a reperdu le forcené
bon hier dans quelque chose tension ya
un jeune homme qui est dans un état
seront voulais vous montrer ses amis et
il dit quelque chose de très important
policiers qu'est-ce qui leur dit papaye
pas bululu où loulou
ou un truc que seul jean michel maire
peut comprendre
jean-michel un truc ça jean michel
marraco des réponses été affirmatif
ecoutez jean michel vous êtes un génie
puisque c'est maintenant dix ans où
travaillent avec moi vous n'avez jamais
réussi à donner une bonne réponse sur
les médias et sa copine sur le chemin le
fêtard se lance dans un show sous le
regard imperturbable de flavien qui
tente de garder son sérieux
[Musique]
ah ah
le jeune homme est dans un drôle d'état
les gendarmes décident de le conduire
aux urgences par précaution il n'y a pas
de guerre des six jours et c'est qu'on
revoie la tête du policier
regardez bien cette dérive est sur le
chemin le fêtard se lance dans un show
sous le regard imperturbable de flavien
qui tente de garder son sérieux
[Musique]
ah ah
le jeune homme est dans un drôle d'état
les gendarmes décident de le conduire
aux urgences par précaution c'est ben
ali et j'avais mal entendu effectivement
c'était une très bonne émission en
revanche légèrement dorées merci savez
c'était une redif et je regarde les
mêmes les rediff avait alors c'est quoi
le problème
merci c'est pourquoi c'était quoi le
thème jean-michel sûr là encore les
gendarmes les le travail les gendarmes
bellino le vent de sud est non non non
c'était quoi les deux autres
les chauffe chauffard nuit d'ivresse est
elle politique wallon c'était quoi fêter
quoi le thème je ne suis pas comme ça
qu'on aime
voilà exactement bravo vous c'est quoi
votre pire rencontre avec les policiers
jean michel vous étiez vous étiez mais
les super héros que le nuage a compté
raconté aux téléspectateurs
je me suis fait arrêter l'été c'était à
4-5 ans à peu près c'est à l'époque je
sortais je ne sors plus tôt si c'est
pour ma maman et des 4 5 heures du matin
je sortais de du travail ou boîte de
nuit je ne suis pas pu bien et j'étais
j'avais un peu fait la fête j'avoue et
j'étais prête des toiles et les flics
m'ont arrêté la bac brigade anti qu il
était m'arrêter et j'ai refusé d'ouvrir
ma la vitre ma voiture alors qu'il sous
les injonctions des policiers et à bout
d'un moment le policier m'a fait un
signe gens ils voulaient me passer
quelqu'un au téléphone et la personne au
téléphone à 4 heures du matin c'était
vous tient au courant
jean refusé de venir la vie et peppone
betty jean luc l'année où cette [ __ ]
ya quand même des choses pour cette
anecdote qui sont assez dingue c'est que
les policiers ont retenu leur téléphone
visiblement et 2 vous répondez à 4
heures du matin vous aventurez pas tout
le temps moi vous savez moi je suis 7
sur 7 24 24 à ses membres et fractionné
mon peuple
c'est quoi mais c'est vrai que comme son
papa mon jour miré fait normal mon chéri
mogil toi c'est quoi taper rencontre
avec la la la police
alors moi c'est la police russe très
dangereuse quand même bon il faut
respecter la loi en russie à moscou
ils m'ont arrêté parce que gérard
problème de visa et il m'a emmené dans
une chambre d'hôtel ils m'ont dit vous
avez le droit en
anglet renouvelant un coup de fil j'ai
passé un coup de fil y avait un regard à
la porte qui écoutait comme ça j'ai
passé un coup de fil en anglais j'ai
passé et du coup après celui tombé sur
quelqu'un qui parlait français ils ont
cru que je passais deux coups de fil aux
gaillards entrer dans la porte
j'ai cru qu'il allait me défoncer il
rigole pas du tout ils ont une matraque
eu la peur de ma vie franchement là fort
de ma vie
moi j'ai pas oublier le bon comprend
valérie bénaïm élargi a été plafonné par
des policiers attendez attendez attendez
un peu d'âme à revenir là dessus qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire valérie
bénaïm ans plafonnée par des policiers
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
est étudiant j'écoutais du côté de la
sorbonne il ya la rue il s'appelle
larmes qui montent comme ça il ya des
croisements premiers lots et eloi galles
marc fauroux qui est passé au vert
et lorsque je suis passé au vert en fait
des policiers étaient en planque et
poursuivez une voiture et ils ont
démarré ils ont déboîté comme ça et nous
ont percuté de plein fouet et ils ont
explosé les camps jeudi explosait
exploser littéralement la voiture il ya
un type en civil qui est sorti qui m'a
jeté une carte en disant rendez-vous
commissariat on n'a pas le temps et sont
partis et ils m'ont laissé comme ça en
plan l'avant de la voiture complètement
explosé et du coup j'ai roulé sur les
chante
jusqu'au commissariat en ressens comme
ça en disant j'ai été en plafonné par
vos collègues
ils m'ont dit de venir vous voir et
voilà et à partir de là les assurances
sont en jeu se dire et voilà mais ben et
ben écoute et valérie bénaïm aujourd'hui
vous avez là quelqu'un quelqu'un une
anecdote à raconter sur pick up à sophie
cottes et ses anecdotes croustillantes
qu'on adore non mais j'en ai plusieurs
avec la police parce que je me suis fait
arrêter plusieurs fois dans des
circonstances assez original et une fois
notamment où j'ai gris et un peu donc la
police m'arrête et caetera et j'avais
des enfants à l'arrière qui s'était
détaché qu'elle a enlevé leur ceinture
j'avais pas de patin son chalet peuvent
donc le policier m'arrête et me demande
d'ouvrir mardi
je vous signale que vos enfants à
l'arrière ne sont pas attachés je me
suis retournée et je crois que j'ai fait
assez preuve de mauvaise foi j'ai dit
mais ce ne sont pas mes enfants mais je
ne les connais pas et ça s'est terminé
que finalement par leur hausse a duré
des heures évidemment et j'ai passé
aussi une nuit
la meilleure des anecdotes 2e jean
deuxième j'ai passé une nuit en cellule
de dégrisement
non donc ça c'était à oued en saas a été
rarement populaire aussi alors la
cellule de dégrisement en fait je me
suis retrouvé dans une boîte de nuit
pareil où il ya eu un peu une bagarre à
un moment donné moi je me suis un peu un
père posée puisque à l'époque j'étais un
peu barbare ou deux un peu bagarreur et
je me suis retrouvé avec la police qui
m'a emmené à l'hôpital par une prise de
sang etc pour voir si j'avais trop bu et
se trouve que j'étais un tout petit peu
au dessus du truc et je me suis retrouvé
donc en cellule de dégrisement pendant
je ne sais pas j'ai passé toute la nuit
là-bas et ça a été mais un cauchemar
c'est juste un an ferme et c'est in
sabah ça m'a calmé je dois dire
qu'aujourd'hui quand je me fais arrêter
par la police
je suis très low profile je dis rien je
dis oui monsieur je donne les papiers du
richesse qu'on lui laisse une troisième
histoire une troisième chance rien dire
mais la première anecdote est mieux
sophie troisième champ de troisième
chance bonne chance une autre avec des
attaques la police a raconté la 3
l'alabama si vous avez déjà un compte
rond raconter anecdotes où j'avais été
soudoyé un pôle inférieur au montant
raconte-nous bien voilà alors à 0 je me
fais arrêter pareil je me fais arrêter
par la police et en fait je roulais un
petit peu trop vite donc le type
paraître rebelote
et là j'avais un léger décolleté comme
ça et je me suis dit je vais être rentré
dans une phase de séduction avec le
policier donc sur au moment où il m'a
dit claude et moi mais pas vos papiers
que ces parages j'ai eu un petit
mouvement comme ça et je suis ici et je
ne sais pas ce qui m'a pris au juste
mais j'ai essayé de faire un petit
mouvement pour lui montrer un petit peu
enfin je me suis dit ça va l'attendrir
pour mumia est ce qu'on voit là sa
collègue qu'il rentrait quoi comment
pour entrer quoi si un petit 1% voyez un
sens une tire la corde au pouvoir pour
un crime quelque chose dans le genre
voilà je me suis dit que peut-être salé
l'émoustiller ou l'attendrir etc
en fait pas du tout le mec c'était une
barre de fer il a rien laissé passer en
plus il était avec mes collègues
féminines qu'il ya les autres salles a
terminé à nous
et quand celles à jean mi les anecdotes
on sait que choisir entre les trois
villes berbères un naufrage l'afp
laurence weill est ce que vous avez
d'anecdotes avec des petits bleus avec
ce porte parole
allez vous vous êtes sûr que vous voulez
prendre du temps d'antenne mom havane
nul
we made easy web au moins comme ça on va
voir si on si nulle que sauf il ya les
hiboux le faire rapidement
c'est un peu nul mais un jour j'avais un
problème de deschacht qui s'allume et et
jean qui arrivait en face sur
l'autoroute et on en est et on m'a dit
que j'ai dit dans mon problème
le ballon c'est mieux non mais ces soins
médicaux quelle anecdote
j'en ai fait froid dans le dos génial
mais c'est pas parce qu'on dit que je
peux la faire
merci les chérir les questions quelles
images chocs
france 2 a tellement
dans son jt un homme en train de se
faire voler son masque de protection
un métro de paris bondé et son respect
des distances de sécurité
une personne de moins de 75 en regardant
affaires conclues ou un élu serrant des
mains à toutes les personnes qui ont
croisé alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
gilles le métro remonte et gilles
regarder ça c'est la vidéo du jour tu
regardes 7h ce matin à saint-ouen en
seine-saint-denis ligne 13 l'une des
plus saturés métro bondé en plein conte
filmant les uns contre les autres
avec ou sans masque tous ont les mêmes
inquiétudes les distances de sécurité ne
sont plus du tout respecte
c'est sûr que non
et puis même sur les surfaces soutient
les barbus portant sur cette ligne un
peu plus du tiers des métros circulent
mais les usagers doivent aller
travailler
ce qu'on dit en première ligne ne se
sentent pas en sécurité dans les
transports formation entendre
pointera dans la série culte et nous
avons montré ces images à ce médecin
réanimateur
c'est inquiétant cette phase est image
là en tout cas elles sont elles montrent
bien que on n'est pas prêt en tout cas
dans les transports à sortir du
confinement même en douce alors est ce
que ces images vous choque
et alors l'elysée annoncé qu'après le 11
mai la distanciation et le bon jazz sont
imposés dans les transports en commun
quelle est votre réaction par rapport à
ça j'ai justement l'elysée dix cantons
ceux des consignes il faudra un masque
pour tout le monde dans les transports
hélas ces pauvres gens secteur sur cette
ligne là ils vont bosser c'est des gens
qui vont faire tourner la france c'est
souvent des gens qu'on les boulots qui
en ce moment nous sommes où nous aident
et on leur donne pas de masque on les
laisse exploser comme ça ils risquent
d'être mal à enchaîner ça me fait mal
pour eux je trouve ça d'une injustice
folle on devrait être capable de donner
un masque à ces gens là
alors que jean michel maire je suis
entièrement d'accord et cherchons à 15
jours nous explique comment on n'a
toujours pas ces [ __ ] de masques mais
le 23 avril donc tâcher pas on n'a
toujours pas de masse au moins en
discuter dans les yeux ou le confinement
est nommé ligue attend les timbres
imposer ces images
est ce que ces images vous choque ou pas
etc et bien c'est évidemment évidemment
eu chaud ce soir c'est pourquoi ça me
choque c'est une obligation de l'état ça
services publics le transport
certaines obligations et a dû distribuer
des masques à tous les gens qui rentrent
dans les transports en commun dans le
métro on retrouve pas en métro sans
masque c'est une obligation on à leurs
noms mais on a gardé seulement 30% des
transports c'est complètement stupide
parce que si on regarde que 30% des
transports évidemment il ya trop de
monde et donc on est dans un vrai délire
parce que d'un côté on a bear balises et
des personnes âgées qui vont chercher
une baguette de pain en leur expliquant
d'y commettre une infraction et qui met
les gens en danger
et d'un autre côté on donne pas les
moyens à ceux qui vont travailler de se
protéger
franchement c'est incompréhensible et si
le 11 mai il n'arrive pas à régler ce
problème ce sera toujours la même
histoire parce que les ampoules voile à
l'école on va les amener pour certains
en transport en commun et on va pas être
dans des conditions satisfaisantes
valérie oui mes petits camarades en tout
10 c'est extrêmement choquant et par
ailleurs c'est pas la peine
à 20 heures d'aller applaudir les
bien que prennent les transports en
commun c'est pas la peine d'aller
applaudir les vendeurs les éboueurs et
s'est éjecté dans des conditions qui
sont où il se mettre réellement en
danger en allant travailler
c'est la première ligne qui sont en
fonte ils font tout pour nous pour qu'on
puisse assurer le quotidien et c'est ces
gens là qu'il faut aider à qui il faut
donner des gants des masses
effectivement les bars qu'on retient
dans métro balas a pesé extrêmement
contaminant l'existence sécurité elles
sont pas là les gestes barrière c'est
impossible
jean michel maire oui on voit bien que
rans comme tous les anciens responsables
politiques sont déconnectés des réalités
même quoi le blem le métro ils
démarchent à 100% les metroid est bondée
où six semaines question 30% et mais en
continuant de temps
non non non confirmées confinement mais
je prends le métro tous les jours pardon
de le dire donc suis pas déconner quoi
que ce soit aujourd'hui on en
confinement donc aujourd'hui si en
confinement on n'arrive pas à faire en
sorte que les gens soient espacés qu'est
ce qui va se passer quand on sort de
confinement alors ça leur théorie des
dépôts est déconnecté des politiques
c'est complètement stupide
alors justement on parle on parle de
déconfinement est déchiré on commence à
y voir un peu plus clair sur le dé
confinement qui devrait avoir lieu le 11
mai le plan déconfinement devrait être
annoncé en début de semaine prochaine
mais ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il ne devrait pas y avoir à
déconfinement région par région
regardez ça c'était sur bfm on l'a vu à
l'instant non concernant l'école on est
sur la base d'un retour sur le
volontariat ce qui permettra
effectivement de renvoyer de renvoyer à
l'école les enfants des parents qui le
souhaitent en tout cas ce qu'ils peuvent
faire autrement qu'ils peuvent
s'organiser autrement ou qui ont peur de
d'envoyer leurs enfants à l'école peut
ne pas le faire donc ça permet
finalement de trouver une solution qui
puisse satisfaire le plus grand nombre
surcharge l'autre point important c'est
la question du déconfinement régionales
on a entendu hier le président de la
république qui a semblé ouvrir la voie à
cette option il faut faire une
distinction même si c'est subtil entre
la différenciation et la régionalisation
pas de régionalisation nous dit l'elysée
ça veut dire qu'il y aura une même date
pour tous le 11 mai il n'est pas
question de rouvrir dans certaines
régions et pas dans pas dans d'autres
région et on attend donc dans les
prochains jours le plan global du
gouvernement pour l'après ans mais voilà
donc région par région c'est exclu
valérie ou est-ce que j'ai l'impression
surtout c'est que l'anneau gouvernement
ils sont en train de balancer des
informations comme des ballons d'essai
pour voir comment la population réagit
et pour savoir si pour détromper d'aller
ou pas et là comme oudi y aura par
région par région
ils attendent de voir comment ça réagit
nous la population si on gueule sont mis
d'accord pas d'accord et bienvenue la
populace à la wii vous la population
puisque nous la population maghrébine et
nous non n'est pas la population nous
nous et voilà bien mais nous voilà si
elle fait la population nous on n'est
pas bien on est à côté nous on n'est pas
là oui gilles verdez région par région
ça aurait été aberrant ça voulait dire
mettez frontières avec des policiers ou
des gendarmes autour d'une région c'est
impossible
là ce que seront positifs même si encore
beaucoup de flou sait que ça va être
sous l'autorité du préfet et des mères
or ce sont les maires qui font savoir
exactement ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
donc je trouve qu'il ya du flou encore
mais c'est un premier pas qui
m'intéresse jean michel maire gilles
joie parce que ça change si c'est des
villes doit pas mettre des bars et
autres débits non plus donc c'est pareil
ah oui oui mais non mais là il ya le
long d'une des régions merde
une fois d'enrichir une fois de plus
l'état se décharge de ses
responsabilités et laisse les maires
décider par eux-mêmes l'école les
parents décident et les pour le
déconfinement les bêtes en kilos
jean-michel il est le meilleur en
télécoms politique oui le renseigner
pour savoir ce qui est cynique c'est
quand fait pourquoi l'état ne veut plus
que les régions qui décide parce qu'en
fait comme les présidents de région se
bouge beaucoup et fonds d action
meilleur que l'état ben le gouvernement
était dans la république en fait une loi
une concurrence politique et c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont décidé de reprendre la
main sur le sujet c'est horrible mais
c'est la règle aller très vite tu
réponds en une minute
non mais là non c'est un point de vue
politique là on n'est pas ici pour faire
de la politique politicienne là vous
défendez des arn que vous défendiez
avancent à pas lent mais je suis une
analyse globale gvt est détendue les
années
jean-mi c'est pas parce que laurence
tamis un bon que tu dois lui parler
comme ça non mais là je parlais de
gilles verdez excuse moi mon moi
aujourd'hui